We're going to use regular expressions,
which are very good at specifying sets of strings
to specify tokens.
Later on we'll want to match a bunch of different tokens
from webpages or JavaScript, and this is how we write out
token definitions in Python.
The t_ tells us--and it tells the Python system--
that we're declaring a token.
The next letters are the name of the token.
You either get to make this up yourself, or in the homework
I'll tell you what I want it to be.
Tokens are in some sense going to be functions of the text they match.
More on this a bit later.
Skip me for now.
Next, we have a regular expression
corresponding to this token,
which in this case, for the right angle token,
there's really only 1 string it can correspond to,
so we've written out the regular expression that corresponds to a single string.
And then here on the last line we're returning the text of the token unchanged.
We could transform it, and you'll see us do that for more complicated tokens
like numbers where maybe we'll want to change the string 1.2
into the number 1.2.
Now it's your chance to define your first token.
What I would like you to do is write code
in the style of the procedure I just showed you before
for the LANGLESLASH token.
The LANGLESLASH token is surprisingly important.
We really need it to know when all of our tags end.
Use the interpreter to define a procedure
t_LANGLESLASH that matches it.